[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حلقه جديده من برنامج مينا
المصدر المهتم بتحليل المشهد الاعلامي
العربي والعالمي اعلام حزب الله يودعون في
سوره البطل في مشاريع يمزق صوره ونشرات
الاخبار تنتقد انثى
استحواذ مصر
يستضيف باحثا بارزا من مؤسسه المحافظه
قبل ايامنا الانتخابات النصفيه
[موسيقى]
في لبنان لم تطوى مغادره ميشيل عون قصر
بعبدا صفحه السجلات الكثيره حول حكمه بل
سكبت مزيدا من الزيت على نار الجدل خاصه
مع قراره الاخير بقبول استقاله حكومه
تصريف الاعمال برئاسه نجيب ميقاتي الذي
كان قد رفض مع رئيس البرلمان نبيه بري
تلبيه مطالب عون وصهره في مساله حصص
التعيينات والتشكيله الحكوميه الجديده
معظم القنوات التلفزيونيه اللبنانيه ودعته
على طريقتها مستذكره ما وصفته بالويلات
التي طبعت سنوات عهد الست خاصه قناه الان
بي ان القريبه من رئيس مجلس النواب نبيه
بري الذي كان عمر قد صعد موقفه ضده مؤخرا
ورق اليوم ان هناك اجماعا وطنيا على الفرح
بانتهاء عهد الذل هناك من اضاء شمعه من
صلى ركعتين شكر من كسر جره من وزع الحلوى
ضربت اسس الحياه السياسيه بالبلد ادت الى
كثير من الانهيار على ابواب تحرير بعبده
على عهد بداويا وانتهى بلا حول له ولا قوه
اقتصار
عام
1989 ومش بتبينك
فاثبت ان كل ما كان يريده هو وسام السيد
حسن
فكما يقول عبد الوهاب بدره خان في مقاله
في جريده النهار اللبنانيه ارثو ميشيل عون
هو لبنان تحت حكم ايران وحزبها وفق الكاتب
يغادر عمري رئاسه الجمهوريه متشاركا مع
حليفه حزب الله او حزب ايران في تخطيطي
بدم بارد لمرحله جديده من الشعور الرئاسي
غير ابهين بالدوله ومصيرها ولا بمئات
الشعب اللبنانيه الرازح بمعظمه تحت خط
الفقر
المقارنه بينما تركه عمر قبل رحيله عن
السلطه قبل اثنين وثلاثين عاما من فوضه
حربه ضد سوريا ضد القوات اللبنانيه وبين
ما خلفه عهده اليوم من فراغ دستوري الى
جانب انهيار اقتصادي كانت حاضره بقوه ايضا
على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
[موسيقى]
فماذا كانت النتيجه وماذا جنت الشرعيه
والشرقيه من العماد عوني
خسرتان الشرعيه والشرقيه حرب
اللبناني 400 الف مهاجر
4000 قتيل الاف الجارحه الات المنازل
المدمره مئات المصانع المتوقفه وفي كل ذلك
47 ساعه عفوا بسبعه واربعين دقيقه صمود
ترك له خيبه بالروح بالدم نفديك يا عماد
انها التجربه الاصعب في تاريخ لبنان انها
المعاناه الاصعب في تاريخ الشرقيه لكن
الانهيار توقف فلقد سقط العماد بعد 32
عاما وفي 31 تشرين يغادر بشلعون قصر بعبدا
مره جديده في ظل اسوا ازمه اقتصاديه
وسياسيه عرفها لبنان
الاعلاميه لتلميع صورته وكان لابد من
الجواب على السؤال ما هي النتائج التي
تحققت مثل ذلك التحالف مع حزب الله ليعون
نتائج نتائج
الجانب الانساني والعصامي المترفعه السلطه
سواء عبر المقابله التي اجرتها معه قناه
المنار او من خلال التقارير المكثفه على
موقعها الالكتروني مصلطه الضوء على فضاء
للرئيس عمر وما حققه من انجازات وبطولات
وفقا تعبير جريده نداء الوطن طبعا بتهكم
تحكي بعاطفي على سماحه السيد سماحه السيد
بيحكي بعاطفي عن حضرتك
شو السر
هو وطنيه مشترك
مثلا مفهومنا للمقاومه
عندما كان يطالب بنزع سلاح حزب الله قبل
ان يتفق طرفا على صفقه عمرك لقصر بعبدا
واطلقت كذا حزب الله في البلد يكرر حكم
الدوله على حساب الدوله
وهو نفسه عندما اصبح رئيسا من قلد سفيرا
النظام السوري في لبنان وسامر الشرف وهو
نفسه ميشال عون الذي اتى الى سده الرئاسه
تحت شعار حمله اعلانيه بين كل قبل جميع
اللبنانيين وتوجهها بزيارته الاولى الى
الخارج الى السعوديه
كبادره انفتاح لبنان الى العالم وليس فقط
الى ايران ليقلص دوره كحامي حقوق
المسيحيين بالشعار العهد القوي فيما شهد
عهده للمسيحيين لمستويات قياسيه مدافع عن
سلاح حزب الله عازلا لبنان عن مضحكته
وهو مكمل للجيش اللبناني ولا سيتناقض معه
رغم العقوبات الامريكيه المفروضه عليه
بتهم الفساد فكما قال لرويترز تسقط العقبه
بمجرد انتخابه
غادر عون السلطه محاولا اظهار نفسه غير
مهزوم معنويا واحاط نفسه بمناصره عند
القاء كلماته الوداعيه وفضل ان يخصص كلمه
الوضع حصرا لانصاره بدلا من التوجه لعموم
اللبنانيين باعتباره كان رئيسا لهم في
كلمته بدات تميزيه وتحريزيه اكثر منها
وداعيه لينتقل العون الى نضال جديد وهذه
المره ليس من اجل تامين مصلحته بالرئاسه
بل لمصلحه
قد يخدع انصاره بالرقص مع الافاعي وهو
لاعب لا تعوده البراعه في العزف على مشاعر
انصاره ومخاوفهم كما قال الكاتب غسان شربل
في مقاله عون مره من هنا ولكن وفق شربل ها
هي تخته قصه المنقذ اللبناني الذي كلف
بلاده غاليا كروايات معمر القذافي وجعفر
النميري وعلي عبد الله صالح وغيرهم قصه
شائكه وحزينه كانت خطبه الوداع محزنه فصل
جليل في علم التضليل
من بيروت تنضم الينا الاعلاميه والدكتوره
في علم الاعلام والتواصل ميشجق التي تابعت
خلال مسيرتها الاعلاميه والسياسيه عندما
كانت وزيره عن كتب مسار الرئيس السابق
اهلا بك ماشي ضياء كيف تصفين المشهديه
التي غادر بها الرئيس عون الرئاسه
لا شك ان
الرئيس عون اراد ااه استرجاع قبيله
مغادراته قصر بعبدا
المشهديه التي كان يحبها عندما كان اا
رئيسا للحكومه الانتقاليه وهمم سكن في قصر
عبده
وكان ينادي دائما همم
المواطنين الذين كانوا يذهبون لي همم يعني
دعمه في قصر بعبدا لانه وقف يومها ضد
اتفاق الطائف في التسعينات وهمم بعد ذلك
نعرف كيف غادر القصر يحب ان يظهر امام
الجماهير ويقول يا شعب لبنان العظيم ربما
اراد استذكار هذه الصوره والمشهديه قبيله
مغادرته قصر بعبدا للمره الثانيه وربما
اراد ان يبارك للناس او ان ينسى الناس
الفكره التي راويدهم دائما لانه عندما
غادر قصر بعبدا في المره الاولى عام 1990
وتعرض القصر للقصف من الطائرات السوريه
وذكر يومها انه غادر القصر العبده الى
السفاره الفرنسيه حيث لجا اليها بالبيجامه
هذه هي صوره التي بقيت في ذهن الناس
تصوروها وتخيلوها اراد هذه المره ان يغادر
قصر بعبدا وانما بمشهديه شعبيه تذكر
بايام العز التليفزيونات كلها همم تراقب
عن كثب بوقت ان همم رؤساء اخرين غادروا
قصر بعبدا ربما في منتصف الليل بهدوء من
دون هذه الدشره مشكله الرئيس عون انه يعني
اراد في الدقائق الاخيره ان يصور للناس
بان ال هو اراد ان يحقق الكثير ولكنه كما
دخل كما خرج وذنب على يعني جول لما ربما
نجح فيه في اللحظات الاخيره هو اتفاقيات
همم ترسيم الحدود البحريه
نجح بذلك كيف تفسرين نجاحك بعدم اهتزاز
صورته لدى بعض جماهيره رغم افقاته
السياسيه الكبيره اللي نقول الامور صراحه
يعني اول شيء همم يعني تم العمل على هذه
المشهديه بعنايه لاننا انبئنا من قبل بان
الخروج نعرف انه يوم الاحد هو يوم العطله
في لبنان وليس يوم الاثنين هو قرر الخروج
يوم الاحد لانه يوم عطله لكي يدفع الناس
لكي يذهب ويشاركه في هذه التظاهره الشعبيه
كما سميت ولكن يعني اذا نظرنا جيدا
المشاريع لم تكون كلها من اللون البرتقالي
الاورنج يعني الذي هو لون التيار الوطني
الحر كان هناك
الاعلام اعلام حزب الله الصفراء وانا اعرف
كيف يحشد حزب الله ايضا وهناك بعض
المقابلات التي اجريت عفويا مع بعض الناس
اللي ربما لكن لم يكونوا يدرون ماذا
يفعلون هناك لانه عندما سئل احدهم مثلا
همم
ماذا لماذا انت هنا لكي ادعم محاربه
الفساد الى ما هنالك سوء ال من هو رمز
الفساد اجابه جبران يعني حتى الذين ساعدوا
ليسوا جميعا يعرفون تماما لماذا هم هناك
لا شك ان التيار الوطني الحر والرئيس عون
لديه همم لا يسال لديه شعبيه معينه هو حصل
على حوالي 100,000 صوت في الانتخابات
النيابيه اكثر بقليل ولكن خسر كثير من
الاصوات التي كانت همم تدعمه سابقا والذين
كانوا يشاركون على طرقات في معظمهم في
غالبيتهم من الفئه العمريه الكبيره ولكن
ذلك لم يمنع مثلا همم خلت همم احد ضحايا
المرفق من ان تذهب الى ساحه ساسين وتنزع
الصور هذا لم يمنع الناس همم في المساء من
اطلاق المفرقعات الناريه فرحا يعني هم
كانوا همم
يعني همم ههه
موجودون في الشوارع وانما الذين كانوا
يفرحون بهذه المغادره كانوا الفئه الاكبر
التي كانت تشاهد التليفزيونات وبعدها وزعت
الحلوى في الطرقيه
دكتوره ماشي دياك شكرا جزيلا لك
فاصل قصير ونعود لمتابع بعده حظر
المحافظين استمر على تويتر حتى اليوم قبل
الاخير من انتقاله لملكيه ماسك
[موسيقى]
الجدل حول استحواذ ماسك على تويتر
الى جعل الفكره تتسرب بسهوله الى وعي
المعارضين لها بقيت المساله جدليه وعالقه
في عمق الكثيرين خاصه لدى تاكيد ماسك ان
المنصه ستبقى للجميع
في امريكا اخذت القضيه وابعادا سياسيه في
مهلل الجمهوريون
امتلاكيون ان ذلك سيشجع على الخطاب
الكراهيه ويعيط جهود مكافحه الاخبار
المظله التي كانت اداره منصه السابقه
تحضرها وفق سرديه لبراريين
المساله ليست استحواذ ملياردير على منبر
اعلامي ضخم بالمساله التوجه السياسي كامل
لمنصه عملت على حظر حسابات منتمين الى
الحزب المحافظ وبخساره البلالين تلك
المنصه المهمه شهدت قنوات مواليه
للديمقراطيين او ليبراليين كثير من التمن
مول حول الموضوع
كتبت انه عصر السوشيال ميديا دخل مرحله
جديده مع استحواذ ماسك على تويتر ووصفات
في احدى مقالاتها وماسك باللاعب الفوضوي
الجديد على المسرح السياسي العالميه اما
بالنسبه الى المحافظين او المنتمين للتيار
الجمهوري فيرون ان استحواذ ماسك على تويتر
قد يغضب الليبراليين لكنه سيعيد مفهوم
حريه التعبير في الفضاء الالكتروني ويطبق
بذلك روح الدستور الامريكي حيث تنشر جميع
الاراء وليس فقط الاراء المؤيده للحزب
الدين
ياسعيد
اذا كما تلاحظون مساله احترام حريه
التعبير اكثر ما يركز عليها اعلام الحزب
الجمهوري الذي استبشر خيرا باقاله ماسك
اربعه من كبار المديرين التنفيذيين في
الشركه والمجتهدمين بعدم الالتزام بالحياد
لا بل بلاعب دور في الانتخابات لصالح
ايصال الرئيس بايرن الى سده الرئاسه وعلى
راسهم المديره التنفيذيه لشؤون القانونيه
والسلامه يا جاجادي
[موسيقى]
والاكثر اثاره بين قراراتها هو قرار جاد
بحظري رئيس البلاد وقتها قائد اكبر بلد في
العالم دونالد ترامب واسرارها على تسليم
مكتوب القرار بنفسها للمسؤولين لتنفيذه
وفقه تسريبات المحادثاتها مع رئيس الشركه
انا ذات لذلك هي التي حذرت حساب دونالد
ترامب على تويتر ما ساعد الديمقراطيين
كثيره في انتخابات 2020 وتم اعتباره ذلك
عملا بطوليا وضروريا بل واخلاقيا قائمه
المحظورين في تويتر تطول بعض القصص التي
تم حظرها كان يمكن ان تؤثر على نتائج
الانتخابات الرئاسيه برمتها كقصه حاسوب
هانتربوينت التي حضرتها تويتر بشكل كامل
قبل ان يعترف اليوم بها رئيس المنصف
السابق جاك دور روسي مؤكدا ان منع نشر قصه
كان خطا فادحا وفقا ما نقلت عنه نيويورك
بوست
طمس قضيه تاتي في سياق تجاهل تام من قبل
الاعلام الاساسيه ومن قبل منصات التواصل
للسلسله تقارير فجرتها صحيفه نيويورك
المحافظه قبيل الانتخابات الرئاسيه 20 20
معلومات اساسيه تتعلق بشركه عائله بيض تم
اكتشافها على جهاز الكمبيوتر المحمول
الشخصي الخاص بنجل الرئيس الحالي هانتر
بويدان المعلومات توثق كيف استفاده من
منصب والده كنائب للرئيس للتكسب
ولو تم التداول بالقضيه كان من الممكن ان
تتغير نتائج الانتخابات برمتها تشير
احصاءات كثيره بينها ما نشرته تايم سبيس
بيتش انه واحد من بين سته ما كان
ولينتخبوا ايضا لو علموا بقضيه حاسوب نجل
هانتر المليء بالفضائح واتضح اليوم ان
المسؤولين عن اداره المحتوى في شركات
التواصل الاجتماعي بينهم المديرون
المطرودون من تويتر بناء على طلب مكتب
التحقيقات الفدلالي منعوا نشر التقارير
الفاضحه لصحيفه من الانتشار
والان في هدوم انتخابات التجديد النصفي
ورغم استحواذ مصر على تويتر استمر الموقع
في غلق حسابات تابعه لنفسكين محافظين بما
في ذلك حساب بحث في مؤسسه هارتج فونديشن
العريقه ومؤسس منظمه غير ربحيه المحافظه
الاستاذ
هل لك ان تشرح لنا لماذا تم حظر حسابك على
تويتر مؤخرا وكيف تفسر هذا الاجراء
قبل ايام من بريد الكتروني يخبرني انه تم
حظريه على تويتر دائما
كانوا يعملون في الكونغرس وجمعيات شعبيه
مؤيده لبعض المرشحين لعضويه الكونجرس ولم
نحصل على اجابه سواء الذي قال ان علينا
الانتظار لبضعه اسابيع حتى يبدا بالسماح
للمحضر لنادي العوده الى تويتر وها نحن في
ضم الانتخابات ومازلنا لا نستطيع دخول
تويتر
منذ نهايه عهد اداره ترامب تطبق تويتر
عمليات حظر جماعيه وفقا لمحاذرها الخاصه
فتتخلص من حسابات ليس بسبب اي سلوك يتعارض
مع معايير منصه تويتر او لقولك اي شيء سيء
بل يجدونك مذنبا لارتباطاتك السياسيه
فيقومون بحضرك وان اردت الاحتجاج على
القرار
يحولونك الى روبوت وكانك تذهب الى دائره
حكوميه باحثا عن المساعده وليس فيها من
يريد ان يساعدك
ولكن بعض يقول ان تلك الاجراءات بحضر بعض
الحسابات هو بهدف مكافحه خطاب الكراهيه
والاخبار المضلله
تويتر وغيرها من شركه التكنولوجيا في
السيليكون فالي هو اللجوء الى ذريعه
الخطاب على الكراهيه او المعلومات
المغلوطه لتبرير الحظر الجماعي لان الجميع
يجب ان يكون ضد التحرير على الكراهيه لكن
ليس هناك تعريف لخطاب الكراهيه اي شيء لا
تحبه الانظمه اول فئه الحاكمه يمكن ان يقع
تحت مسمى الكراهيه والان والخطاب المحافظ
هو المنتقد للوضع الراهن ونحن غير مرحبا
بنا على الانترنت ولا على الاعلام
التقليدي
ومساعدهم تهديفه الى تركنا نتحدث مع
انفسنا فقط او نتواصل عبر من غير معروفه
او غوره في المحادثات الخاصه
لكن لا يسمح لنا بالتحدث على المنصات
العامه وقد وصلت الامور الى حدها فلا يعقل
ان يكون مفكر ما محروما من التواجد على
المنصه ويبدو انهم لم يعد لديهم قدره على
التحمل كالسابق
نا الايام الاولى تبدو مباشره فقد تخلص من
المجلس الاداري وهذا امر جيد لان هؤلاء هم
الاشخاص الذين وضعوا الاساسات لمنظومه
الرقابه التي نخضع لها حاليا
لكنه يبقى فريق السلامه والنزاهه
المسؤولين عن تنفيذ ارشادات وتعليمات
المجلس والتشبيه للامر هو انه فصل
الجنرالات وابقى الجنود لكن الجنود ولا
وهم ثابت مع النظام السابق وسيحاولون
امر على ايلون ماسك قدر الامكان وجعله
صعبه لكن هو عليه ان يستعجل الامر ويتخلص
منها هؤلاء كي يتمكن من تنفيذي خطته الخاص
من الصوت وسائل الاعلام على الحياه
السياسيه في الولايات المتحده
عاوز
يتمتعون باكثر من مجرد تاثير بل هو تحكم
قوي بالجهاز السياسي الامريكي وهم من
يقرروا لكل عضو بماذا يغرد على المنصه ومن
هم يسمح لهم بالظهور على البرامج
التلفزيونيه ومن هو مخول بالتغريد بقصص
جديده ان لم يعجبهم حديثك
سيقدون على وجودك على المنصه وليس امامك
يجرى متاح يعيدك اليها
بالتاكيد ما نراه الان هو حسابات محظوره
لاصوات شابه فاعله ومحافظه كان بالامكان
ان تؤثر على نسبه المشاركه بالانتخابات
وعلى التجارب الانتخابيه كذلك التي
شهدناها في 2020 عندما كان شباب يغريدون
بشهاداتهم عن وقوع ممارسات غريبه في احد
مراكز الاقتراع ويبدو انهم
بتاع ميدون ان يؤخرونا حتى نهايه الدوره
الانتخابيه ولا يبدو انهم مهتمون بالفعل
لاعادتنا
[موسيقى]
لليوم موعدنا يتجدد الاسبوع المقبل شكرا
لحسن المتابعه واليكم
[موسيقى]